sama sandals and of course swimsuits all
made famous by Brazilians but lately
it's a one ingredient wonder that's
dominating the export markets coconut
water the bland but oddly refreshing
drink is a favorite right here in Rio
and now it's setting off a beverage
brand war back in the States
that's because bottling up this
Brazilian Beach favorite is big business
the water from young green coconuts
jam-packed with electrolytes and
potassium has become a consumer favorite
as a natural alternative to sugary
sports drinks coconut water has kind of
been growing at a you know twenty to
thirty percent rate in the past couple
of years right now one of the fastest
growing categories out there which is
why the biggest u.s. beverage brands
have bought in coca-cola dished out 15
million to acquire Zico brand coconut
water in 2009 and PepsiCo followed suit
a year later when they added the Ont
brand to their portfolio but it's an
independent new york-based company that
leads the market for this trendy
beverage vitae Coco
they say sourcing coconuts primarily
from Brazil has been a key to their
global marketing success well as a US
company doing business in Brazil there's
tremendous benefit to try to capture the
spirit of Brazil and as our brand is
positioned as a coconut water in the
space as a Brazilian brand truly born on
the beaches of Brazil that's in stark
contrast to Zico and oh and II both of
whom source their coconut waters
primarily from Indonesia in the
Philippines and it's paying off for Vita
Coco revenue has grown from 20 million
dollars in 2009 to an estimated 300
million this year despite coconut waters
rapid rise in popularity fears of fans
still loom in a fickle health beverage
market Vita Coco recently settled a 10
million dollar class-action lawsuit over
claims that the brand was falsely
advertising the health benefits of the
beverage yet the company's maintained
its market share in an increasingly
crowded marketplace nearly 200 coconut
water products have joined Vita Coco on
the shelves around the globe coconut
water is definitely here to stay I think
seeing you know sort of the tip of the
iceberg right now